what was it like when you read
the episode 5 script and you found out
who sabrina morningstar was going to see
when she walked through the mirror
because i yelped
yep yeah uh truly a yelp a yelp is
really appropriate
i feel as if um
when the script was written i don't
think we knew
that we had confirmed the antis
so it was like sabrina walks through the
mirror
and sees two familiar faces that you
might know
and i was like is this what i think it
is
and everyone was kind of whispering and
rumbling throughout that like oh my god
i think we're really going to get the
ant are we going to get them are we
actually going to get them
and then they showed up and it was the
most surreal thing ever i'm so happy we
got to do that i mean
our show wouldn't exist without the
passion for the original show so i'm
happy we got to loop it all in
that really was like the ultimate payoff
to wrap up here i do want to ask you
both and i've only seen up to episode
five so i don't necessarily know this
answer myself so
now that we know that the show is coming
to a close with part four
can we expect a conclusion for your
characters
or is it kind of like an open-ended
thing where
you never know it could come back and we
could learn more about them
um i think it's probably both at the
same time i think that we approached the
finale as a finale finale
uh and i'm happy we did that because i
think the fans deserve that kind of
closure
having said that i don't think that
greendale would ever not
uh be exciting i i i doubt that
uh sabrina's life would be anything but
uh
filled with lots of you know highs and
lows
and greendale is not just gonna become
like a
chill place so there's always room
to to come back but i at the same time
think that we gave people like a ton of
closure so
i like hearing that i'm so pumped but
i'm sad at the same time
but seriously thank you for everything
you've given the fans it's been a real
pleasure to be covering the show for so
for a couple years now and just being
part of that conversation
so thank you guys and huge
congratulations thank you so much